hello
everybody
i'm hans kim
um
i'm having a good
time i think it's funny that um
[Music]
guns are now a subject of discussion
everyone's talking about guns nowadays
uh guns are
like a
cool way to express yourself and think
about things and stuff
um
i think that guns are
dangerous
that's what makes them cool
um
i like the look of a magazine it's very
functional
it does what it has to do
um
and
it's
very effective
it's
um
scary and cool and awesome
so i love guns i have a gun
um i love guns
a lot
um i have one i want to start shooting
it i have
i haven't gone to the range yet
i want to go to the range soon
hmm
i have a gun
um
yeah i mean i think
oh [ __ ]
i think guns are
you know
like a fun thing to do
obviously they have no
um
they're more
more harmful than they are good i think
if you look at other countries that
don't have guns i don't think you need a
gun to have a good country
i don't think people should be able to
kill each other
um i think overall if and nobody can
kill anybody
then uh less people get killed
how hard was the gun license test
i'm in texas baby there is no gun
license test
uh yeah you're probably just joking
around there's no gun license test you
can just get one but a car
you have to
go to driver's head and stuff so maybe
we should treat guns like cars
um
so what i had to do was i had to prove i
was from texas all i needed was a
driver's license but i wasn't going to
get a driver's license because then i
would have to get another type of
insurance i'd have to get my
license plate
renewed to texas license plates
[Music]
and all that
so i didn't want to do that so all i did
was have a passport and then i
registered to vote and used my address
so that they could send me a little
postcard and then if they had a little
postcard
then uh i can prove i live in texas and
that's all they need to sell me a gun
you have to be a resident of texas for
them to sell you a gun once you're a
resident of texas
it's pretty easy but if you're not then
uh you'd have to go to a private seller
or something
uh
what's my thoughts on the philippine
elections i think the philippines have
been [ __ ] by america and they're now
just like a client state and they're
just trying to imitate their big brother
america
is that the philippines where like
politicians get killed all the time i
think uh america
established a bad precedence of
not only do you have to be campaigning
for your citizens but you also have to
be eyeing big brother and making sure
you're doing what he wants because if
you're not then he's going to
murder you
but she just armed the third graders
yeah we should make schools into like
banks school uniforms should be made out
of kevlar nice
it's like
isn't it sad isn't that like
a really sad society where you have to
have your children
go to school in a
fortress because
people just keep trying to shoot them
and kill them
people just keep looking at our society
and being like this sucks i think that
the babies here need to die
and uh it's sad that uh you know so many
people think that uh
our society is horrible and kill the
most precious things but it's not like
kids did anything to school shooters
especially not elementary school
children not at that age
i think they just go for the target that
is the most
eye-catching and the most [ __ ] up
thing that they can do
and this is what they choose like
whatever we hold the most deer is what
they're gonna shoot so it doesn't matter
if we arm the kindergarteners they're
just gonna move on to the next thing
whatever else we like they're gonna
shoot up the kentucky derby or the
stable or
you know a puppy farm or something
that'll get our attention the only
reason they're doing it is because we
like it and we love children
and so they're trying to hit us where it
hurts
you should could have gone to a garbage
sale or a car
it's a garbage sale
or a gun events
i think the thing about buying it in the
store is that
i like
that i know where it's coming from and
it's like hey this is a
it's a thing this is like a thing that
is gonna
i think um
it's gonna work it's not gonna be [ __ ]
up if i buy it at a gun store so i just
like the safety of it if it's just some
dude that had it i don't know how he
took care of it and all that we should
go back to virtual schools
yeah i mean we could do a lot of things
differently
they just use bombs which is a sad which
is sad and truth
i mean i don't know if they'd use bombs
a lot of people don't know how to make
bombs bombs are harder to do than guns
guns are easy to kill people with
uh and bombs are like sort of like a
nerdy way to kill people you gotta like
set it and then just
do it and then you're gonna be like oh
nice i set the thing off
um and then you just have to get off on
the uh idea of killing people but like
if you want to kill people
and just be there and see it then it's
better to have a gun it's more visceral
and fits with what whatever they're
trying to do
um
i think that
i mean
i think that um
what we need to do is give uh young
adolescent men a future a society they
can hope for and be a part of and be
excited to be a part of
i think that uh we need to value people
more and give them purpose and meaning
in their life
and that if we just set them up and be
like hey you're gonna have a hard
childhood and hopefully it can be a
cubicle worker or a fast food employee
then they're not really going to value
their life or the lives of others
uh but if we're like hey you could be an
astronaut or a scientist or a
you know like a jet pack instructor
and they'll be like oh i'm excited about
life let me not kill people and let's
relax and have fun and have a good time
in life because i have a future that i'm
working towards but if you have no
future for them and they see no future
in the society they live in then they're
not going to try very hard
and i think that we should treat people
and value humanity higher i mean if we
adults don't value humanity and just see
them as
cattle that we can make money off of
then kids are going to see people as
little
cattle that they can use to whatever
they want they can use to express
themselves
and we just don't value
humanity that much
so we're just treating people like [ __ ]
and so our kids treat people like [ __ ]
and then they go crazy and then they
just take uh our lack of humanity to its
logical conclusion and be like well if
these people are worthless and are just
mcdonald employees and little
decimal points on a stock
price then
like who cares if we kill them it's like
0.5
on the dao
exchange or whatever it's just all
numbers people are just treated as
numbers by our society and economy and
adults
so
if that's how we're treating people then
that's how our kids are going to treat
you we just don't value people very much
and that trickles down into the way we
treat everybody and that's how we treat
our children our children feel that
effect of
treating people like numbers they're
moved around their their moms are
struggling to make ends meet
they're poor their dads are locked up in
jail to make license plates
for a non-violent drug offense so like
people are cheap there's no reason to
value humanity i don't value myself i
don't value others but if people are
beautiful and
precious and artistic and creative and
beautiful and awesome then it's going to
be harder to kill people and see them as
just
nothing
[Music]
i just think that we don't treat people
very well
and one of the side effects is that kids
who
don't know
how where our
lack of empathy ends just takes it far
to the extremes
um
but this is like a version of what we
all have is we have uh
disdain for humanity and people and we
don't really treat each other very well
um
so that's the adults but the adults have
like barriers to the most extreme uh
conclusions that our lack of humanity
uh gets to
uh that our lack of humanity would get
us to if you were like a little kid
so we have like oh i hate people but i'm
not gonna shoot them i'm not gonna you
know commit crimes and felonies against
them but i still hate them i'm gonna
legally treat them like [ __ ]
if we just
taught these kids how to legally
do the same thing they did with the gun
but do it economically then they'd
become really successful in business
um
don't kill them why would you kill them
when you can
make them work for you for 7.25 an hour
you think killing them is evil try
enslaving them and making them work for
you and pay for your yacht
that's true evil these [ __ ]
kids these days so [ __ ]
lack of discipline they don't know how
to [ __ ] really be evil
like me
we don't treat the poor well
there is a line
yes the poor they're not humans
we treat human beings well but the poor
we treat those people badly don't uh
you think about the fact that you could
become poor at any moment because
uh if you want to get rich you have to
take risks and
taking risks is looked at as cool
um
yes always be having confidence in
yourself you are one of the few that
deserves the humanity and basic human
rights to other people who look like
people they're not actually people they
don't deserve it
they deserve what they're getting is
sleeping out on the street
only people who are worthy deserve to
have basic human rights and you are one
of those
ignore the nagging voice in the back of
your head that tells you that you are
one of the
you are the same as the people out on
the streets
you are better than those people
hans can you talk about why you switch
out of mech e
uh you're so emotional and get mad get
even
um
yeah i mean i've been working on a bit
but it's kind of i don't know it's not
working out that well
um
so hey hans how can i become worthy
um
become an economic elite
oh i forgot i'll get up tomorrow take
risks and be rich thanks dude
yeah i mean you got to take risks to be
rich and
the people that are rich they are always
taking risks and they're always at the
at the
about to be
poor you know it's like it's in the back
of their mind
that's what i'm saying i'm not saying
all you have to do is take risks i'm
saying that people who
who
are trying to make it in the economic
game take risks and they're always at
risk of being poor therefore they're
always at risk of being treated
inhumanely
that's in the back of their mind and
that feels a sort of desperation in our
society i'm not saying just take a risk
and you'll be rich
i'm saying that uh we're all
precariously approached on top of our
uh
on top of our economic position and at
any moment we can be toppled and that
affects the way we treat each other and
that affects the way we think about
ourselves is if we treat poor people
badly then we see ourselves as that and
one way to combat that is to be like oh
this
isn't the right way to treat people so
just because some people get treated
horribly doesn't mean they deserve it
and uh i don't respect how this society
determines who deserves human rights or
not
and i believe all people deserve human
rights regardless of their situation and
so i'm not going to internalize
society's rubric for grading humans
and
come up with my own rubric and morality
besides societies because society is
[ __ ] up
what's wrong playboy i like that i
should sell all my board apes now
speaking of do you have a financial
advisor yet
no i'm
i'm two-thirds done my chicken pop pie
and i'm enlightened and am enlightened
there's something to risk capital poor
people take less risk because we're
more afraid to lose what we have yeah
poor people take less risks that's why
they want to preserve the system they're
like oh [ __ ] this is really really
precarious for me right now i just want
to keep everything the same everyone
don't move we're just going to keep the
system how he is how it is right now
and i'm gonna try to figure it out don't
try to improve it you're gonna make it
worse
by improving it let's just keep it the
way it is and the more time i can spend
in it the better i can get
at the game and i can make it
um so the pecking order hans ago
malaysian people always have wise things
to say ancient chinese wisdom
yeah that's a good way to um
ignore asian people
it's like oh so wise
anyways
it's boring as [ __ ]
let's talk about something cool that
makes my genitals tingle because this
asian person is just making my soul feel
weird
um
but some rich people were once poor
i mean some rich people were poor
but most people in america were rich
more than other countries
because there's this measure this
uh this uh
this
number that you can look up called uh
social mobility and turns out we're 27th
in the world in social mobility which
means if you're in the bottom
25
what are the chances that you're you get
to get out of that and we're 27th in
that
which means like
ideally
uh if you're born in the bottom 25
there's a 25 year in the top 25 there's
a 25 you're in this
you know
75 to 50 there's 25 you remain the same
and 25
25 to 50.
but america doesn't do a very good job
of helping poor people get to where
they're going
um people are dumb get used to it rich
people rich people looking to hide out
in buckers i mean people are dumb but i
think it's because that's how we were
trained to be we don't train people to
be anything other than cubicle workers
and uh you know like
little cogs in the machine taught to be
boring and stupid so that you don't
challenge the system
the most important thing is that you
don't challenge the system
any additional benefit you can provide
society
is uh just extra we don't need that what
we really want is just that you don't
knock this over so the first and
foremost
thing that we uh help people out with
is so that they don't try to overthrow
this [ __ ] that we got this is good don't
knock it over
don't [ __ ] try to change it to keep
it the way it is and we train people to
just [ __ ] leave it alone that's the
most important thing and then on top of
that they're like okay here's some
education and one plus the seven
and all that but that's really secondary
to not uh knocking over the jenga pieces
in the way that it is
um
it's better at making poor people
is this doug robb's podcast or hans cams
you
guys coming back to michigan anytime
soon but guys uh do you mean just me and
by soon do you mean in uh
some day it's on my link tree
linktree.com slash
link tree slash
dj hans kim it's on my instagram and
twitter dj huntscam instagram and
twitter check it out check out the link
if you want to go to a show in detroit
i'll be there soon next month i think
then i'm going to go to
boston and then i'm going to go to
florida i'm going to go to tacoma i'm
going to go to seattle
there's a lot a lot of things happening
why do we spend so much on military
because that's how we got to where we
are you think we conquered countries and
staged coups in costa rica just by
sitting on our asses
we got to where we are in the dance by
[ __ ] conquering [ __ ]
if you are a hot girl that got into
hollywood by being hot you don't just be
like well done with that time to turn
ugly now
you're like i gotta keep this up keep
injecting me and [ __ ] i need i need to
keep the hotness you want to keep that
that thing that got you to the dance
because you're like well if we did this
to other people what if someone did this
to me
this is the natural way humans are
humans are naturally aggressive and
violent and taking [ __ ] over because
that's what i wanted to do so i guess
everyone is like me
everyone is exactly like me there's no
other way for people to be but the way
that i am and we should have a society
that
is designed for people like me
and uh
make sure that we just check violent
people and not encourage peaceful people
and then there's some due to my comedy
circles are huge creeps who verbally
assaulted a host at the restaurant i
work at
should i call them out for it or act
like it didn't happen
depends on what they did how bad it was
and why they did it and
who they are and where they are in the
comedy
scene
i would just like
go to an open mic and be like this guy
[ __ ]
a waitress or whatever
um i think that uh
old people
are wrong
i'll say israel
what a great subject
um
um
welcome to orange county
uh
will you be on west coast norcal
no not really let me pull up my
calendario
calendario
so i'm going to be
in
uh
plano san antonio fort worth in june
coming up next week
then i'm going to go to
uh stay
here
eddie i might go to fort worth or dallas
on 11th
then uh
man it's so grainy
i don't know why it's so grainy
anyways i don't think that's helping it
um i might do this show josh smith
addison improv
in addison
texas
i think that's near houston
i'm going to detroit
right here 2425 and then boston the 26th
and then i'm going to las vegas july 1st
for the mgm garden arena then i'm going
to do florida this date might not happen
let me make myself small this date might
not happen
these dates are happening i'm going to
side splitters in tampa
mike lee
um and then mad caps
in
florida look it up i don't know really
where they are and i'm gonna go to
tacoma then seattle then richland
washington on august i might go to
canada
but yeah other than that i got nothing
going on
but let's go to link tree
dj having this game
so
plano coming up san antonio fort worth
and i'm doing the dating show i like
doing the dating show it's fun you
should check it out
uh it's on youtube fort worth and then
boston tampa florida
uh new smyrna beach
this is a month behind i got to change
that
so there you go there's the thing figure
it out i don't want to talk about them
anymore have you ever tried the keto
diet i'm on the keto diet i try not to
eat a lot of shitty food but hey look at
the thing is i'm not a [ __ ] athlete i
can cheat if i want to so i cheat all
the time but generally i try to be on
the keto diet but i do eat ten grams
and i do
i do eat pizza or whatever i
i don't really keep a strict diet
because i'm
pretty fit
right now for now it's going good
um
addison is dallas fort worth metro [ __ ]
i'm going there again i go to dallas so
many times
what is being the local road like
compared to being in the road on the
road like compared to being hitting
local mics
it's a lonelier longer sets
artistically more fulfilling
you're performing for more trump
supporters so if you're into that that
should be fun for you
i don't like it that much i like
performing in cities which is cool
because now
i've been able to hit more cities and
liberal places
so i like that
liberal cities are harder to break into
it's easy to go anywhere and meet a
trump supporter and perform for a trump
supporting crowd
they're like [ __ ] they're everywhere
they'll just take any comedy they can
get because
they can't pick and choose like liberal
cities can liberal cities can be like
hmm i do not like this guy next
so it's harder to break in but once you
can
the money can be better
but also um
it's uh
it could be worse too because it's so
much more expensive
um what is your biggest regret uh
sex is athletic though
are you on steroids no i wish i need to
get stronger i've been kettlebelling
more and more
but
you know i i'm not as strong as i want
to be i have a neck injury that i'm
constantly [ __ ] with so
that's just sort of what i'm doing
i don't know where in canada i think
near where jared nathan lives is where
i'm supposed to go um
but i might not go there i don't know i
haven't talked to him in a while
um so what do you guys think about the
uh
politics
i think that uh overall the political
landscape is [ __ ]
um
[Music]
let's hear let's pick a better
poster
let's pick
um
hi
background desktop background
um so i like
um
disney channel
um
i liked it a little before high school
musical i was a little too old for high
school musical by the time i was
i was out of high school
i was more into it
[Music]
i was more into disney
channel uh when i was like really small
no smaller
uh but yeah i mean my sister who is six
to eight years younger than me she was
really into disney channel
and high school musical and i thought it
was ridiculous and i made fun of her for
it and i just
thought it was a stupid thing to be into
and
i feel bad for teasing her and bullying
her about high school musical and making
fun of
high school musical
but i thought this was a good background
because it's cheerful and happy and just
uh good vibes and just chill and nothing
too extreme it's like the opposite of
the gun
hey have you ever played golf with tony
no how was your question
so i should say the same for the viewers
pleasures
but i don't think the viewers would like
it if i stayed the same
i think uh being a dynamic and
versatile person has its benefits and i
know like some people can only
appreciate
um
who a celebrity or a famous person or a
person an artist or if
a musician or something if they're
exactly the same but i think that uh
that that's not always the good and a
good answer because then you become
stale and then you become lazy and
you're just like i just have to be the
exact same way i am right now
but then if you try to be too artistic
and change all the time for no reason
then it can be bad because
then you're like changing things that
are actually good that you should have
done and you're just trying to be
fancier and trying to
do [ __ ] that doesn't need to be done and
you just uh
do the good stuff but you're like no the
good stuff is bad i need to do bad stuff
to be good
and you can be overly artistic so i'm
trying not to do that but i'm gonna say
less asian jokes on stage
um i think that i've i heard from uh
some people that i respect about like
their thoughts on that [ __ ] so i do want
to do less asian jokes and less hacky
asian jokes there's there'll be like a
couple that i do but i think there's a
couple that are hacky that i can just
cut out of my act all together
so i'm excited to never do some of those
jokes again
milly marx is uh the porn name of the
wonderful comedian molly vivint and this
guy vorak says hans you should be in a
million marks video um i don't want to
um i
don't think i have to do porn yet
i don't know if i want people to see
me in that way
um
but hey why not right radical honesty
let's just show everyone everything who
cares
um
hans who are your inspirations and
comedy my inspiration in comedy is
obviously joe rogan um when i was a wee
litter comedian i would uh listen to a
special and write it down word for word
i think that his
uh ability to talk about what he's
actually interested in and make it funny
instead of like being a slave to like
dick jokes and
um
you know like improv games he can talk
about anything that he's actually
interested in make it funny
and i think that the subjects that he
covers is so
um universal and uh like stuff that you
would actually want to know about and
talk about
so i think that's cool
and um
that's one of my inspirations and plus
his ability to make a career doing only
things that he likes to do
um i think is amazing and he's created a
wonderful lucrative life for himself
outside of the normal paradigm which i
think is healthy because i think
the normal paradigm makes you crazy and
[ __ ] you up
i am shook i am no too sick but i also
respect how hard you shot me down i have
some reflecting to do first last
i agree korean here
you're funnier than jimmy okay
someone
i think he spelled his name wrong keep
killing it
i mean
i might be funnier than some people but
i'm not as funny as other people so i'd
rather just not compare
i'd rather just
exist and have other people exist and
not have to battle anybody and lose or
win
instead just i would like everyone to do
what they're doing and have a great time
doing it uh it's not a zero-sum game you
know like you can have multiple
people in the art space you can you
don't just need one person who's really
good at volleyball you can have multiple
artists and in fact an artistic scene is
helped by diversity of thought and
opinion
and uh we should be encouraging of a
more
uh
intellectually diverse group of
comedians but also it is important to do
better and to compete and to excel and
to not be lazy and be like oh that's
good enough i got a couple chuckles here
you should push yourself to be better
and all that
um feel free to compare it's okay to
think about things
yeah i mean i've thought about things i
mean we should you should think about
things that are helpful and productive
sounds like communism hey hans how's
your weekend been it's been great
so communism is just whatever americans
uh think will help black people
uh if it helps black people it's
probably communism oh you want to feed
the poor or create less
violent communities that's communism
[Music]
tell us how you really feel austin
so i um
i think it's great that uh
communism uh was a thing in the past and
now it's no more
i think that
america started the cold war because
they didn't want to see another economic
system
exist
so they were like
only this one can be a thing anything
else is a sin
and we will bomb you and
have sanctions on you until you do what
we want
i mean there was no reason for
america to start a war with russia just
because they tried a new economic system
and then a lot of the um
a lot of the
bad parts of communism
is actually a response to being
economically attacked by the richest
country and all of its richest allies in
the world
um
and
what we associate with communism is just
a result of us attacking people oh you
don't want to do communism that that'll
result in me hitting you in the face
i don't want to do communism because i
don't want to hit myself in the face
uh any country that tried communism got
a visit from the cia
and
was
murdered in [ __ ] so i don't think we can
say that we really
gave communism a shot it's like we were
trying to destroy it the whole time
anyone did it even in guatemala
i mean it must be frustrating if you're
the cia you know no matter how many
brown people you kill
communism keeps popping up
the idea of people controlling their own
resources instead of letting exxon
valdez
drive a [ __ ] tanker through their
coral reefs and pollute their
uh sensitive biomes with an oil spill
that uh that idea is uh very popular
like maybe we should uh help the poor in
our country and not give all our natural
resources to a foreign company
no
you must let us rape you
or else you are a communist and you will
be attacked
um it was affected none of people
powered any at one
and one anyhow if you be great at any
sport so they get people are like yeah
communism it's like you can't think what
you want you can't have bread and you
have to
uh you know
work
really hard and make weapons and [ __ ]
but a lot of that is because america was
attacking
the country in question like
yeah you don't have bread because the
economic powers in the world russia or
america and france and uh
england and germany eventually
are like
keeping you at uh
at uh in a poor state they're not
letting you trade with each other and
they're
[ __ ] with you and like that you can't
think what you want that's what happens
in wartime when you're at war like
during world war two you couldn't just
go out into london and shine a
flashlight even though that's like a
freedom that should be afforded to
everyone as the ability to do a rave
outside there were no raves in england
which is very unfree during the battle
of britain because they were at war and
if you're at war with the greatest
superpower in the world
you
have to crack down on your citizens so
america would just attack a communist
country and be like look they're so
oppressive to their people yeah because
you're attacking them
like they have to have all their ducks
in a row they can't have [ __ ]
infiltrators and spies sneaking in
because if they're nice and relaxed and
open to the people you're gonna sneak a
spy in there and shoot the [ __ ]
president
like you try to do in cuba multiple
times
and then they're like oh cuba is so
shitty it's like there's no
new cars there everything sucks yeah
because america is sanctioning them it's
like how do you not see that like how is
it that hard to understand communism is
greater physical comedy like when kim
jong-un strapped his uncle to a post and
turned him into red paste with an
anti-aircraft gun a lot of that is just
american propaganda like a lot of this
crazy [ __ ] that they say about north
korea like how
everyone in north korea believes that
kim jong-un doesn't [ __ ] that's just
like
americans trying to make korea sound
ridiculous but
yeah i mean north korea isn't great it's
a small hermit kingdom
that
relied on the soviet union for
everything and the soviet union went
bust i mean how well do you think south
korea would be doing
if russia nuked america and there was no
more america anymore there are vassal
state
um
south korea that is
i'm an american right now
but uh
um yeah
i mean north korea is uh is a sad little
place
but uh you know at least it's not
[ __ ] el salvador or some of america's
closest allies
this is not northern mexico
um
so have your daughters born
what does that mean i don't know what
that means have your daughters born
come to wichita kansas i'd love to do
they have a comedy club there what is it
like there do you have a lot of money
you can give me when are you in houston
next
i hope soon if you can be great at any
sport which would it be and why
probably ping pong so that i don't have
to wear out my body too much
probably something easy to do like
not football
not mma
i mean although the implications would
be awesome like i could beat anyone up
that'd be awesome
uh
oh pepe is in el salvador right now
how's el salvador is it better than
north korea
um but i love el salvador
i know that ms-13 is from there so
i don't want to talk too much [ __ ] but
i heard that there's a lot of them
coming in
in the caravan across the border
people were like why is there a caravan
what is a caravan i think it's like
people are like
you know like
you want to do things together like
where it's very social animal so if
a bunch of people decide hey
uh
we need to go to
um
we need to go to america and it's like a
mass movement then it's going to be
easier to do
and
you know we don't we do everything
together we don't just do specific
things together we do uh everything
together
and so like uh we're social animals so
we're like oh we want to this is not a
big image
we want to go to america they're all
going to do it together
like if you were in that situation would
you rather do it alone or would you
rather do it with other people
why is it so tiny all the time
is this el salvador el salvador doesn't
have large pictures
this is el salvador this mountain is
something they're very proud of
apparently
because it's in everything i click it
always has this mountain in it
and they have a like so el salvador is
pretty cool
what's wrong with el salvador military
posted up in every corner
is that a good thing
is it that's what we need in
kindergarten is to make it more like el
salvador we need the military in the
kindergartens
we need a [ __ ]
uh
battalion per
school
and then
it could be like a shooting gallery
it'll be like [ __ ] fallujah in every
high school it's like an insurgency we
got to win the hearts and minds
are you still living the van life nope
not living the van life hey what's up
hans i just smoked some han solo burgers
um
in san vincent vicente vicente is good
number 13 hiding like rats right now no
lie they have no signs to call one two
three
if people see any gangster they have
signs to call one two three if people
see any gangsters
see i think that's good because ms-13 is
a little crazy but
these things will keep popping up
because there's no money in the legit
economy so people are going to [ __ ]
find a way to make it on their own
without having to do the legit economy
because the legit economy will pay you
17.
7.25 dollars an hour probably even less
in el salvador so as long as a legit
economy is not
uh helping people then it's not going to
be
a legitimate choice that people can make
so they're going to have to resort to
uh using the resource that is people
um
to their benefit and
joining gangs gangs is like where you
turn people into
property and you uh start trying to mine
people
for whatever value they might have
which is sad because it's inefficient
like a farmer has to farm and then he
has to give some to the mobster
and that's how the mobster lives is by
[ __ ] over the farmer you need a
hundred farmers for one mobster
and they take a lot of it and it's just
not an efficient way to run an economy
[Music]
instead you should have faith in the
system and not have people violently
extorting each other and everyone can
focus on something
and instead of [ __ ] each other and
taking a percentage and making it less
efficient of a society you all do
whatever
you want to do and are good at and then
it makes the world a better place
uh
and um
everyone is efficiently making things
without having to sacrifice a percentage
to a mobster it's going to protect you
from other mobsters
it's a service that only exists because
other people are doing it like if we all
decided to stop being mobsters there
would be no functional value to it but
the fact that other people have it means
you have to have mobsters on your side
so
it's just a industry that arises when
there's no legitimate option
in the economy
and people just start
trying to
mind each other how much room should you
take first time enough to have a good
time
what do you think about the lizard
people flying ufos around
um i mean if they're lizard
people wouldn't they be
terrestrial they're from the earth what
are the chances that lizards evolved on
another planet very very low
so they're probably from our planet so
they're not aliens so there are
beings on this planet that have more
advanced technology than us
that's so bad the past thank goodness
people are feeling safe again and
opening up stores in the small towns
again
yeah
um i'm glad things are getting better
and el salvador
hope uh america doesn't stage a crew a
coup there
um
i was high i don't think i'm high right
now
but the mob protected the farmer what
does the farmer need protection from
other mobsters so the mob only exists
because mob other mobsters exist
uh the ugly honest truth is northern
europeans and east asians are the most
productive people on earth and no amount
rainbow and butterflies is going to
change that
yeah because
everywhere else has been destroyed by
colonialism
i mean south america is still being
colonized economically
uh i mean look at uh how it started why
does everyone speak spanish there
everyone was [ __ ] so hard africa has
been [ __ ] so hard middle east has been
ravaged with european wars uh
you know everywhere else has been [ __ ]
that's the reason why
northern european and asians are doing
so good is because everywhere else is
[ __ ]
[ __ ] up and [ __ ]
um
but yeah i mean i think if everyone got
there it was left alone and they had a
a good time of life then uh i don't
think northern europeans would be so far
ahead because
um
if
they were just fuck-ups and they could
never get their [ __ ] together then why
would
europeans be so afraid that they are
gonna get their [ __ ] together and stage
crews in their countries all the time
um
nothing else is on i'm dominating the
market right now
i don't want to go out
um yeah i guess
i don't have to go out if i don't want
to
so um
they have been a hundred of wars in
europe and east asia yeah but
we survived relatively intact
india got [ __ ]
china got [ __ ] they're just getting
their [ __ ] together
um china got [ __ ] by japan and britain
can we get a peek of that
kilotons
merch
and will you have merch when you get to
boston
you're buying crypto what do you do for
fun on sunset
so um
what do you guys think about uh
the economy
um johnny depp and amber heard
um
school shootings what do you guys think
about school shootings
i think that we need to have
background checks and
i think we need to have
a registry of guns
i think that we need to
um
have psyche valves and maybe classes
like driver's ed for guns
i think just giving everyone a gun
willy-nilly
is gonna lead to a lot of violence and
death
and i think that we should um
have some uh
some barriers to entry to for guns
and maybe we don't have to sell assault
rifles
i
i think
that assault rifles
are
unnecessary for people to have if you
want to overthrow the government
uh do it already
y'all haven't done it once with assault
rifles
but i guess it makes our country more
prickly uh if we're ever to be invaded
by another country it'll be harder to
take us over you know there'll be a lot
of insurgencies and a lot of fighting
from wild country folk as they try to
invade us but who knows like you never
really know until it happens how a
country's gonna respond like maybe
we're gonna get [ __ ] really hard and
fast and we're not gonna have time to
stage
a rebellion it'll be futile
there'll be no point in small arms fire
but uh yeah i mean is
being prickly against uh occupying
country
invading our lands is that really worth
the dead children and the violence and
the threat of guns
and uh always looking over your shoulder
and always being like oh that guy might
be able to kill me right now like is it
worth it to have that
when the benefit of having assault
rifles is that we can fight off an
invading army like how likely is it that
there's an invading army that's going to
come i mean
war of 1812 is the last time someone has
invaded america
and
uh small arms helped i mean pearl harbor
good luck
shooting the zeroes with your ar-15 i
mean i'm sure it wouldn't be pleasant
but
yeah i mean it's it's just
not a good way to have a civilized
society just have guns everywhere
um and other countries prove that
i but
it took me about a month i'm glad i got
this gun before all this [ __ ] went down
i have a gun and i
uh will get a gun because uh if it's
that easy to get a gun why wouldn't i
uh i have to respond to the environment
that i'm in instead of responding to an
environment that i wish to create that
isn't existing yet if everyone has a gun
then i'm getting a gun and plus it's fun
and it's cool to have
gun licensing system probably the most
practical way to control psychos
but what would be the super expensive
boat that would be super expensive to
implement
gun licensing
i mean just have the dmv do it
that'll that'll de-incentivize people
from wanting to shoot up the school if
they have to go there and wait in line
and take a ticket i do care about you
hans but when i see people with illegal
arms to carry i feel safer
what if when you see
people with illegal arms
that they're carrying then do you feel
safer
and also
that's a symptom of a sick society if
you need assault rifles and legal guns
to keep it safe then things are probably
falling apart and you're just trying to
put a band-aid on it in the form of a
gun if you need a gun to keep law and
order in your society
maybe something that you could do is
feed the poor and make sure no one wants
to kill your country by being a good
country and not invading other people i
need my ars because of antifa and blm
showing up to people's homes and
extorting them not because of invading
armies
um
well yeah you could be like that couple
in st louis who had their guns outside
their house and they were yelling at the
protesters
that's not a very tactical move
because then you alert people to your
presence and people don't like you and
you give them incentive and
you know mortars bombs
those are things that people could uh
implement
use on you
even if you have an assault rifle um but
yeah i mean if you really think antifa
and blm are marching up to your door and
threatening you then um it's a sad
country that you live in and don't you
want to fix it
you just want to threaten everyone with
violence and keep yourself safe while
the country goes to [ __ ]
are we back
i think i'm back
bulletproof the walls and doors make
every other electronics operator from
central by a person like a prison voila
i think that if you make schools like
prisons it's a very sad state of affairs
and very expensive you think gun
licensing is expensive try putting a
[ __ ]
bulletproof
everything in a school you're probably
joking but
instead of making our schools like good
to withstand attacks how about we stop
creating people who want to attack
children
uh it's like a very weird thing like
people don't always want to attack
schools and children it's something that
can be avoided it's a very avoidable
problem and we should work towards
finding the solutions to the very
avoidable problem of children being shot
by people
instead of bulletproofing the doors and
i think one way to do it is to treat
people better poor people need more
money i don't think anyone but i will
protect myself and family at any cost
i mean yeah i mean it's good to protect
your family and yourself at any cost but
i think it's bad to fantasize about that
situation coming up and being like oh
i just want that to happen so bad
because i want to protect myself a lot
um but yeah i love protecting myself
it's uh
something that i don't try to think
about or try to fantasize about because
i think if i don't do that then i'll
respond
more
authentically in the moment instead of
being like oh [ __ ] this is the thing
that i prepared for i gotta [ __ ] gear
up and [ __ ] do it the way that i
wanted to do it i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
in this situation
uh let's get let's be object oriented
let's uh achieve
the
the goals that i want to achieve
and then i won't be having this other
thought of like all the other [ __ ] all
the other [ __ ] in my head
uh giving me emotional stress during an
already stressful situation have you
have you ever considered
military in your life
yeah i've considered military in my life
i've considered military when i was uh
attacking the sovereign nation of el
salvador
and i was like
i'm considering whether the military
will try to stop me from
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
should pharmaceutical odds be allowed no
says dj albums i don't think
pharmaceutical ads should be allowed i
think the doctor should make the
decision instead of a patient being like
oh that sounds cool let me try it
because it's not like a [ __ ]
uh beanie baby it's not a [ __ ]
mcflurry it's a [ __ ] drug that uh if
you let people just medicate themselves
i don't think that's very healthy i
think that's the uh failings of a
medical healthcare system and because
our healthcare system sucks so much we
got to figure out our own [ __ ]
uh medication and we
were like what do i have to take let me
figure it out on my own pharmacist but
if you had like doctors and readily
accessible doctors and people would be
able to be like oh i need to go to my
doctor and have him figure me out an
outside third-party influence who's
well-trained and
motivated
and
as a part of a society that respects and
honors his contributions
would be uh helpful
feeling to prepare is prepared to fail
get some close quarter combat training
if your weapon is for self-defense
um i would love to um
i would love to you know be able to do
john wick [ __ ] and learn how to clear a
room and
you know clear
room is clear
but uh i honestly don't think it's that
useful i think a better use of my time
would be
spent
being a nice person saying hello to
everybody shaking hands
not pissing people off not
[ __ ] anybody's wife
and then i think that will help me live
a very long life without having to learn
how to
shoot a gun inside
because i want to be able to hear
when i'm 74. i don't want to have
ringing in my ears because i was i shot
a gun inside a [ __ ]
stairwell
um
where do you get your comedy ideas from
i get my comedy ideas from
jokes.com
also just living life and finding out
what i'm interested in and thinking
about it and thinking about
the process of getting good at things or
the process of learning new things and
oh look look at that quirk in the human
experience that is relatable
that everyone goes through when learning
something or when confronted with
something that they're not used to why
don't i write a joke about that about uh
something that uh
whatever
have you been in a fist fight results
uh i was in a fist fight in new york
city i was getting off the subway some
guy was standing there eating a burrito
angrily staring at everyone coming off
the out of the subway stop so
i stared back at him
uh not in a good mood i guess
uh and i stared back at him and said
what are you looking at i said [ __ ] you
and he threw his burritos at me and
charged at me yeah without any sort of
idea of what the [ __ ] he was doing so i
just [ __ ] i popped him twice i gave
him a little
little jab in the face
and i didn't really hit him hard
um
it was [ __ ] weird uh i didn't hit him
hard
um
and it just felt weird it felt like i
was touching some dude's face it's like
oh my fists just touched this guy's face
like i want to touch my friend's face
i'm touching some random guy's face
right now like i didn't want to touch
his face
and then he started [ __ ]
doing some [ __ ] so
i grabbed both his arms and i [ __ ] oh
and i uh
i bested him in the [ __ ] arm
grabbing thing
and i like spun him around and didn't
really know what to do with him and then
i walked away
but in the middle of the fight
he was like oh he's attacking me he's
attacking me back up whoa back up and
then i would back up and then he'd come
at me and i'd go at him again and go
like every someone look at this he's
attacking me
so it was like this guy was a dumb [ __ ]
as a comedy fan i'm very proud
i'm very proud he says
so he says uh stand-up comedy
[Music]
i like stand up comedy kill tony
i've been keeping up with for five years
ha ha ha ha hello oh i'm grappling the
finally video never happened i didn't
get video unfortunately i was just
walking back to my home i was at in new
york city walking back to the creek in
the cave
got off 21st and then alst or jackson or
whatever
and this guy was just eating a burrito
very angrily staring at people and i uh
didn't didn't like that and so i fought
him i said [ __ ] you and then he charged
me
but uh what were you doing before comedy
i was failing in school i was cheating i
just barely passed i got a shitty
internship
i mean it was a great internship
but they didn't really trust me or give
me any responsibilities and the intern
they had after me they gave a lot of
[ __ ] too so i was like what the [ __ ] why
did they just hate me
but obviously they didn't think i was
cut out for the stupid mechanical
engineering
world and then i did a
little uh startup company lackluster
performance just trying to get by not
really motivated to help some guy create
surgical tools which were cool but it's
just not my thing
um
that's cool thank you for visiting
um i love you i love koreans i love ufc
um i would love to uh you know hang out
with you or something
um but yeah was the time out
uh
oh yeah and then i uh got into the
startup company the surgical devices and
then i got fired from that for being a
little pedantic little [ __ ]
and um
then i
got uh
got to my parents home in seattle and i
started doing comedy and i've never
stopped since nine years now constantly
open miking and now stage
shows
how old you are 32.
you ever been to tegu
south korea i hear i lived there for a
year amazing memories
uh temperate
attempted to live in korea or el
salvador for retirement
i don't know i i don't think i've been
to tekku
i've been to seoul obviously i've been
to tejon i've been to busan
i mean i was only there for a day and
busan is cool how do people get the
motivation to work a nine-to-five for
decades seems like a complete waste of
my time
well
here's the thing it is a complete waste
of your time a nine to five is just a
place for your soul to die
but it's also useful in some scenarios
you know they do create apps and you
know create bridges and [ __ ] on nine to
five schedule
i just think overall
um
i just don't think uh yeah that's that's
the best way to spend your life i think
uh
nine to fives have been hijacked by
corporations to make money out of people
and if you sign up for a nine to five
you're getting cheated you could set up
your own company and get paid way better
for your labor than a nine to five
i think nine to fives are bad
uh
in the typical corporate structure i
mean you have to set up a work schedule
somehow but i think nine to fives are
designed to milk as much labor out of
someone for the least amount of pot
money possible
i don't think it's healthy
that process when developing jokes this
is my thought process when i'm
developing jokes i hope this is funny oh
[ __ ] this better be funny if this isn't
funny i'm gonna [ __ ] kill myself
i know that i think this is funny but
you remember that one time you thought
it was funny and it wasn't you [ __ ]
suck this better not suck like last time
[ __ ] figure your [ __ ] out i'm in
engineering school right now barely
passing and spend most of my time
watching comedy on youtube hey that's
like me except i was playing starcraft
2. i um uh also barely passed at a 2.6
or 2.7 gpa grade point average
and i got out of it did not really have
much luck with jobs and started comedy
and started living my life the way i
wanted to instead of
uh shaping my life around the company
and making money for them i instead
decided to live my life the way i wanted
to and
uh utilized uh my time and resources to
make my life better instead of making
some company
more money and i developed independence
and confidence in myself without the
whole uh
structure of
uh
nine to five corporate life
and uh i became resilient and able to
pick and choose what i wanted to do with
my life without fear of
death or
not surviving
and
and i chose this life which has almost
zero nine to five and zero corporations
and i'm having a great time
um
dish
the goods on joe rogan and watch your
viewers go from 71 to 1000 haha are you
just on here killing time
um
yeah i mean obviously you don't really
respect what i'm doing here but uh you
know at least
i'm uh
i'm up and adam
you know it's uh i don't mind the low
view counts i am practicing and getting
better and i hope that one day that uh
this will be
a fun way to
uh
talk and get some ideas out and do
everything
uh do something creative were there any
jokes that you thought were hilarious
but no one found a funny yeah
a lot of them
uh 80 men aged 80
have prostate cancer hans have you had
korean texas bbq fusion not yet i would
love to
korean texas bbq fusion that sounds
amazing
chad asking the hard-hitting questions
are you in a romantic relationship right
now yes i'm dating the beautiful rachel
uh we have a very great relationship i
enjoy spending time with her
um
and um
we're very good for each other i hope
and i have a good time with her i have a
van wants to start a van moving service
called men with a van
with men with ven
venn diagram underachieving on route to
doing what you want i quit my nine to
five so i can work 24 7. don't get
into crypto and nfts
i'll take plant-based will be the
fat free sugar free folly of the 2020s
i mean i think sugar-free isn't a folly
i think sugar-free is good for you um
i think that uh in college i was very
depressed and sad because i didn't know
my future and i was like well i'm bad at
school so i must be a bad person i must
not be as talented and worthwhile to
society as my friend lokmal
but the thing is that it's very
inconsequential
and
school is uh
[Music]
just a set up to becoming a docile
member of society and if you love the
society then you're that you're in then
please contribute to it but if you
think that there are a lot of flaws with
it
then just doing school is not very
healthy or advisable
um
what kind of music do you listen to at
hanskin
i like nickel creek i
like um
[Music]
i like uh blink 182
unlike others
is there actually the one filling your
head with the ideas of america being
responsible for third world countries
existing
um no i'm uh more of a communist than
she is she
isn't the communist unfortunately
i mean european
colonialism
obviously wasn't very good
what are your thoughts on acid compared
to shrooms i feel like shrooms is better
i feel like acid is uh
it hits stronger and it's scarier and
you don't really know where it's gonna
go
well i meant like fat free was all the
rage in the 90s but it ultimately became
awful for people because most companies
just supplemented with tons of sugar
oh yeah everyone was trying to be fat
free
that's so unhealthy
um
oh my god why is it so tiny
i'm gonna download it
i don't want to download it
yeah i mean i hope that we can make food
really really dope in the future
i think that it's unhealthy to be eating
unhealthy food and it's healthy to be
eating healthy food and we should be
eating more healthy food and we don't
eat enough healthy food
and there's not enough incentive to eat
healthy food because everything is about
profit and it's profitable to sell you
as much [ __ ] as possible and it's not
profitable in the short term to feed
your healthy food and everything in this
society is about short-term profits
hans i'm getting munchies what should i
make choc cheese or nacho
i would get
some chicken
some chicken quarters
how is it staying motivated with all
your success um i mean
i
i hope i'm motivated it's hard to tell
if i'm motivated or not i try to write
new jokes i wrote 2 000 words today i'm
podcasting today
uh i used to do a lot more shows and
stuff
but whatever
i used to do a lot more mics
um i enjoy
um
doing comedy for people that actually
want to hear comedy now i enjoy that
there is a lack of negativity in my life
from open mics i think that
just because you're successful and happy
and satiated doesn't mean that you get
lazy and you get tired and you don't
work as hard i think that's just what
happens
when you torture people in poverty
and then they finally get success and
then they don't feel an obligation to
the society that tortured them and that
only showed them approval at this
certain point in their life
but
i was never really
suffering under poverty i was just
visiting poverty as a tourist
um and
i think that um
i think it's just uh
i i
i i'm not motivated by just trying to
survive i'm not motivated by just trying
to
be a have a huge following or anything
although that would be nice if i had a
huge following i'm motivated by like
trying to create some art and some
[ __ ] [ __ ] that will last like a mitch
hedberg album or like a brian regan
album i am motivated by that kind of
[ __ ] i want amazing albums that people
can listen to and that i can impact
people through and show people my
perspective and be like hey this was me
this is my meat body this is my
perspective a human on earth this is how
i saw the world and i want to
um impart that upon the world and have
them do what with it what they will
hopefully
a lot of people find some thing helpful
in it
and i tried my best to
[Music]
do do stuff that will help people or
like have an impact and stuff but yeah i
mean my goal was never just to
have a
room in a house on the first floor and
uh you know
live in a live in a uh drive a van
around and you know it's just like
i this is this is a good step towards
where i want to go
but it's not not where i want to be
at for a long time or what i want to be
known for
this is a positive step in that
direction and i still haven't achieved
it
and i don't feel like i have achieved
what i wanted to achieve and this is a
very great motivation
and it happened really quickly and it's
amazing
i mean i've been doing nine years but as
when it started happening it happened
really quickly and i think this is
amazing opportunity
um and i just don't want to [ __ ] it up
uh that's my main thing is like i have
this foothold i don't want to let it go
or [ __ ] it up in any way and just keep
it going
so glad you're proud to accept that
super chats carry on
uh when are we going to see you on jerry
hell yeah hans just don't die like mitch
we need
our
tour choice i bet his parents
were supportive of him doing comedy yeah
they let me live with them for five
years for five years i wasn't working i
was just living with my parents going to
open mics every night
and that really helped and not a lot of
people can do that and i try to use that
to my advantage
i know that i'm super privileged and
then not everyone gets to do that but
someone has to we can't all be poor
someone has to be the rich trust fund
child
and uh you know it turns out it's me and
maybe in the next life it'll be you
um but i mean
i don't think that i'm better than poor
people i just think that uh
poor people need to get their [ __ ]
together
no i i just i
i don't know like i had this advantage
uh where my parents let me live with
them and i also have a lack of shame or
lack of uh
morality or the society's morality or
whatever their moors are i don't really
care if it looks stupid to live with
your parents for a long time so
um yeah i mean
i uh
i i used uh
the advantages that i had and the love
of my parents i monetized that and
extracted the resource that was their
love and turned it into a free room and
board
and i used that to get good at comedy
and all that and you know like
yeah i mean that's
it's fun it's it happened i
i i think it's a good thing to uh
have people be uh living in relative
luxury you know
like we don't need everyone to be poor
and starving that's just a quirk of the
society that we live in and that's not
the only way to create art and we should
learn how to create art in
relative wealth
because if we don't then we are doomed
as a species
[Music]
we can all be poor
communism hold my beer yes communism is
a poverty cult
we uh have one toothbrush that we all
share that's the goal of communism is to
have everyone be poor and that's not
just a result of economic warfare by the
largest superpower in the world
attacking you
um can you
move yourself to the side across the
backdrop a few times
that's exactly what i did why what
um
[Music]
yep we need more supportive parents
thank you for being a friend
uh hans you're
coming in georgia tech history
did you know that uh
jeff fox where they used to go to
georgia tech he lived in the east campus
during freshman year did not graduate he
dropped out out of freshman year as my
recollection
um
and um
he uh he used to live on the east side
of campus and uh i used to live on the
west side so
i mean i did live in a van for four
years so maybe that cancels out my
parents
um letting me stay in their house for
five
i uh experienced some abject poverty uh
just as a tourist it wasn't real it was
just fake poverty
but it was still poverty nonetheless so
i experienced some lows but uh how much
do you calculate that into the equation
of our use uh rich yuppy trust fund
child
um
because four years living in a van does
not cancel out 25 years living in
a
suburban community in
um
seattle the suburbs of seattle how long
did you live in a van and what was your
setup like four years and uh there's a
video
online if you want to look it up
what is your favorite one liner
my favorite one liner is probably mitch
hedberg
[Music]
mitch hedberg's
one liner was
i used to do drugs i still do but i used
to too
i lived in a communist country for 13
years it's not as good as it sounds
either you'd be in jail for several
years for doing stand-up about certain
topics yeah that seems like the result
of america waging economic warfare on
you and so you need to keep all your
ducks in a row look how many rights we
gave up after a couple people in a cave
flew plain into our buildings
now imagine if that person in a cave was
the largest superpower in the world
leaning on you economically for 50 60
years and let's see how many rights we
give up
[Music]
i think that
i think that a lot of things about
communism is very
misconstrued and that
the reason why it keeps popping up is
because it's the there's a lot of
tenants in it that we need to adopt
and we refuse to uh because we're scared
of the word
and because
[Music]
we are secretly supporting the
billionaires that brainwashed us into
uh preserving their wealth over us dogs
are always in the push-up position did
you ever do drugs more than when you
lived in the van
uh no i probably did drugs more in the
van
do you think political correctness
affects today's comedians and material
yes
a lot of people are pro a lot of people
are against i think a lot more people
are against political correctness and
that informs their comedy but that's
always been the things from the 90s
i loved living in a van four years
didn't really seem that bad to me i
could have done it longer i enjoyed it i
couldn't do it in texas for four years
but maybe in a more moderate climate
like seattle
or
i would migrate
so
new york was great it got hot and cold
but
um yeah i mean i loved living in a van
i
could do it a lot longer and i do love
living in a house it is way more
preferable
it is not preferable to live in a van
but
it's fun there's other things that you
get
but yeah
it's like a fun thing to do to be like
do i really need to live in a house to
value myself and respect myself do i
need to be respected by other people
uh
to be
um
to have confidence in myself or can i
just [ __ ]
uh
you know
um
can i just respect myself for being a
person i don't need to like very few
people in history have had a
a a an electrical outlet
and air conditioning and heating and all
that and they still consider themselves
people so most people did not have the
modern luxuries that we have so i don't
need to have that to
be uh to have worth in myself i i value
the things in my life uh like my
intellectual
abilities or the ability to be
intellectual or think and like you know
have fun and be creative and laugh and
eat and drink more than i enjoy my
ability to live a comfortable life and
buy myself air conditioning
um
that's not really an important thing to
me i know for a lot of people if they
don't have the
minimum of
modern conveniences they don't feel
worthy and that they don't feel like
they're part of society but i never
really wanted to be a part of this
society anyways i wanted to laugh
at the society and make fun of things
that i don't like about it and maybe
create a better society but
i don't really want to be a part of this
i mean i am a part of this society but i
don't want to be like
fully in support of everything that
happens in this society and i think
there's a lot of things we can improve
and i don't really need to be a part of
this
because i don't really
like a lot of what happens in the
society so i think it's
it was good for me to be away from that
and be like oh i'm not really a part of
this even though i was
a lot of people would say that i wasn't
kpop is used to troll communists
i'm having trouble dealing with my adult
adhd issue and depression with my wife
and it's going
to drive a wedge in our marriage and our
family any advice
wow that's very honest
uh my adult adhd issues and depression
i would say that that is a bunch of buzz
words um i would like to know what the
real issue is what are you really
thinking are you sad that you only have
you can only [ __ ] one person for the
rest of your life even if your wife is
beautiful that's don't
uh you know you get tired of whatever
you have so maybe that might be
depressing but
i think that there's a deeper issue at
hand
either money or sex and i think that
the adhd and depression maybe you don't
have a very fulfilling job and maybe you
don't feel like you're
useful
in the world and that your true
contribution to the world is being
unheard
um
and i would love to
uh maybe see you [ __ ] a bunch of people
and have a new job
and have a new hobby and new friends and
i think that would cure a lot of the
adult adhd and depression obviously not
if it's
at the uh
without your wife's consent i wouldn't
want
to have you [ __ ] a bunch of other people
but uh
you know maybe if uh if you want to
preserve your relationship with your
wife you probably shouldn't be [ __ ]
other people too much
but yeah i mean
as long as she's cool with it or maybe
whatever oh you have a family
um yeah i mean i think [ __ ] a lot of
other people is very helpful
and it brings you closer to humanity and
gets you to be nice to people that
aren't your wife but i don't know
it's kind of hard to [ __ ] other people
when you have a wife and a family so i
guess i would just suggest having a new
job and maybe
uh
trying to convince your wife to let you
[ __ ] other people
i think that would cure your adult adhd
and depression as [ __ ] a bunch of hot
human
beings um
[Music]
ever meant to alaska
hanzo
uh no man did not try meth bro i tried
meth
uh you sound like an
existential dumpling
you sound like an existential dumpling
okay
do you smoke weed if so how much and if
not why i smoke weed i smoked weed today
it hurts my
respiratory tract so i try not to smoke
too much
i'm coming to dallas soon check my
calendar link tree
um
i
i'll try those things good advice money
well spent you spent money
i didn't get that [ __ ]
that's why all the top toxic comedy
anime furry avatar k-pop stans and
twitter are so hilarious because k-pop
isn't always will be a capitalist
creation
i don't know if you really want k-pop to
be your
uh shining example of capitalism it's
not known for its artistic merit
or its ability to withstand
uh
a second glance
uh it's pretty shallow [ __ ] music uh
which is great you know
teenagers exist they need they need an
art form they can easily grasp onto but
they're it's really not there's really
isn't a future
in k-pop i don't think
in shitty music
hey why don't we try to make music as
mass-produced as possible you know music
the thing that expresses a human soul
can we crank it out like a factory
is tim dillon one of your favorite
comedians working right now yeah
who is one comedian you are looking
forward to meeting
louis
siskel
okay uh john mulaney
uh
i mean i already met marcus normando
i already met shaunamus gilossimos
i met a bunch of ron whites i met
so many great comedians
amazing
i love just sitting there and being
silent and being like look how
respectful i can be
oh wow you're a very funny comedian look
at me respecting you right now i respect
you so much
please do not turn your gaze to me in
anger i am but a wee little boy i cannot
defend myself against your attacks you
are the superior i am the inferior
please do upon me what you will i am
your servant
i will fight and die for you my liege
did you acc live in your van without
parents money
did you act live in your van without
parents money i mean i got a loan from a
family friend but i paid it back
um
parents money and parents money yeah
i didn't really use my parents money
that much
after i'd left it at the age of 28 after
28
i stopped using my parents money like a
19 year old i fully grew up after i've
used my parents money for 28 years the
rest of the five years i haven't used it
that much
have you ever met doug rob
where's the new girl friend tonight
probably in her house i think she said
she was editing have you done dmt with
joe rogan nope i did it alone if you met
louie and he asked if it was okay for
him to whip it out would you let him
i'd probably depend on the situation
um
nope don't think i would i'd be like no
i don't think so sorry man
and then we could have a talk about it
like it wasn't that funny when i did
that
um
do you think that uh
that the uh general state of the world
is a good one
what the world needs now is love sweet
love
so the world is a very beautiful place
uh as you can see the sahara is empty as
[ __ ]
there's a little wrinkle
europe is very full look at all the
borders the board on the water is where
it's all [ __ ] lit up
like crazy it's like a little outline of
the border and lights
and then here you can see
i think that's moscow and how all the
[ __ ] webs
go to it and the city centers
cities are so beautiful and they are the
uh human race
coming together and making an awesome
thing have you ever met bilbert nope
i have not met
is your kill tony under song under wk
ready to die yes hey hans kim what
happened to the ukrainian lady um i met
my other girlfriend and uh
sadly we had to break up
also not like you wouldn't join bts in a
heartbeat if you had the chance
you think i would join b what would i
join bts as a comedic relief
i'd be the goofy guy with the big head
rolling my head around bobbing around
like a bobble head and with these all
these beautiful
athletic sexy little asian boys
dancing and prancing around and i'm just
lumbering around with my giant head and
they have all have tiny little heads
all right so they're kind of nope
um
yeah i mean
i think that um
it's crazy
how the world is so beautiful
all right
i should probably get off
but thank you guys for tuning in i hope
that
you enjoyed yourself and i will see you
in